Hello! Welcome to Michael's Better Business English!
This month, we're looking at how to interrupt.
Now, this is quite a difficult skill for many Japanese business people...
...and the main reason is culture difference.
There are big differences between cultures in interrupting style.
For example, in Japan, often it's not polite to interrupt.
People instead wait for a long silence as an opportunity.
However, in other cultures such as America or Europe,...
...interrupting is much more accepted.
And we often use much shorter silences.
So, how can you do this?
Here are four steps to help you.
First, silence.
As I mentioned, don't wait for a long silence.
It might never happen in an English business meeting.
Second, use body language.
Leaning forward, making eye contact with the speaker, making a gesture,...
...that's a good way to catch the attention of the speaker and help you interrupt.
Third, project your voice.
Don't speak down into the table.
Instead, project your voice loudly and clearly,...
...then there's more chance you'll interrupt successfully.
And finally, use people's names.
John, Mary, Michael.
If you use somebody's name,...
...people catch that very clearly and they will automatically stop speaking.
So, for example, "John, may I interrupt? How much did you say?"
Use these four techniques to help you interrupt successfully.
Thank you and good luck!